[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas en Ucrania los
combates se centran en torno a la ciudad
de bajmuto en la provincia de danés el
grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner asegura
tenerla prácticamente rodeada al tiempo
que ha emitido reclamos en contra de
Moscú por la falta de munición aunque
las tropas ucranianas han sufrido
importantes bajas Aún se niegan a
Rendirse kiev anunció el envío de más
soldados para la que es hasta ahora la
batalla más Sangrienta desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa lo que pudieron
comprobar nuestros enviados especiales
Es que solo hay un corredor que conecta
con el resto de la población del donbas
en control de las fuerzas ucranianas
acompañaron a una unidad de drones en
una de las poblaciones que todavía
sostienen la defensa de Ucrania el
informe es de Catalina Gómez Ángel
miquel conate y oreste jalatson
es otra mañana más en la que estos tres
hombres llegan hasta esta población
cercana bacmut para Elevar sus drones
las fuerzas rusas se encuentran a menos
de dos kilómetros y piden ocultar su
ubicación
solo una semana atrás no atacaban con
esa cantidad de artillería probablemente
los rusos han traído más munición y más
unidades de artillería
en cuestión de minutos instalan su
equipo en los últimos días los rusos han
acelerados ofensiva contra bacmut la
tienen cercada por tres frentes y buscan
encerrar a la población y a las tropas
tal como lo hicieron con la ciudad de
Mario Paul
esta población donde estamos es
especialmente importante para ellos
porque es estratégica en su objetivo de
acercar a bahamut por esa razón los
estamos sosteniendo
estos drones son los ojos del resto de
los hombres que defienden las posiciones
pero operarlos tiene grandes riesgos
sus operadores son objetivos de las
fuerzas rusas que saben que sin estos
aviones no tripulados los ucranianos
están ciegos
pasa la atención y por fin logran
levantar el suyo
en la pantalla se ve como un caserío es
atacado allí vive el enemigo dice
yuroslav
literalmente ayer hubo muchos rusos aquí
los expulsamos a todos y no queda
ninguno al menos en este momento ellos
corren por los campos y se esconden en
los surcos de la vía especialmente en la
noche
cada vez más arrasada solo el centro de
la ciudad está bajo control ucraniano
pero su cámara no tiene la precisión
suficiente para apoyar al ejército desde
esta posición para eso necesitan drones
militares que piden a los países aliados
los drones civiles en algunas ocasiones
pierden señal y el control y eso hace
que los derrumben porque este equipo
está hecho para trabajar en las
condiciones donde todo funciona bien el
sistema alerta que se acaba la batería
es hora de desmontar
tienen que dirigirse a otra misión la
defensa de bakuth no para Aunque nadie
Está seguro Cuántos ataques más puedan
aguantar
una de las principales consecuencias de
la guerra en Ucrania son los miles de
soldados mutilados por los bombardeos y
las minas Irene sabio y Héctor estepa
uno de los equipos de enviados
especiales de France 24 se desplazaron
hasta uno de los principales centros de
rehabilitación de Ucrania ubicado en el
VIP donde diariamente reciben a docenas
de pacientes veamos el informe
el fuego de la artillería y las miles de
minas sembradas en los campos ucranianos
han disparado el número de mutilados en
Ucrania el técnico nasar bañuke nos
muestra algunas prótesis que se fabrican
en este centro dice que los pacientes
están aumentando y muchos tienen
amputaciones graves
a los soldados se les dan los primeros
auxilios rápidamente les ponen los
torniquetes pero a veces esperan hasta
dos días para ser evacuados
el soldado raso Igor un ex minero se
encontraba en una misión en el área de
gersón en octubre cuando piso un
artefacto explosivo el estallido le
arrancó el pie y parte de su pierna
derecha
nos vamos acercandonos a gersón ocupamos
algunas posiciones enemigas de los rusos
llegamos hasta el río ni pro y pisé una
mina antipersona por eso lamentablemente
no pude llegar a gerson
los amputados de la Guerra de Ucrania se
curan En centros como este donde hay más
de 200 pacientes en listas de espera
muchos mutilados también están
mentalmente exhaustos es lo que se ve en
los ojos de Eugenio trabajaba con
policía y cuando empezó la guerra se
alistó como voluntario dice que está
intentando recuperar su vida pero es muy
duro y lleva meses de terapias
ya no puedo luchar tal vez podré
ocuparme de tareas administrativas pero
no lo sé intentaré recuperar mi vida
será difícil pero lo intentaré
buena parte de los tratamientos y las
prótesis las pagan países extranjeros
Ucrania no tiene recursos suficientes
para cuidar de todos los que se han
dejado sus cuerpos en los campos de
batalla
en Panamá la contaminación por plástico
es una de las principales problemáticas
ambientales que enfrenta el país y las
aguas residuales el principal foco de
atención diariamente cientos de litros
de agua sucia corren por quebradas con
Destino final el océano Pacífico el
informe es de Oscar sulbarán
de agua sucia caen al día en esta
quebrada aledaña a una pequeña
Urbanización a 30 kilómetros de la
capital panameña es parte del sistema
fluvial que termina en el océano
Pacífico en el lugar existe una planta
de tratamiento que nunca funcionó
según Magda esta situación se repite en
otras 87 urbanizaciones cercanas al
lugar de la provincia de Panamá oeste
nos preocupa Pues que estamos
contaminando no solamente esa quebrada
estamos contaminando el río aguacate al
final y al final el mar y cuántos años
ya llevamos más de 12 años en esto
estas tuberías drenan el agua sucia de
las casas el lugar donde terminan ese
río que ha cambiado su aspecto en las
últimas décadas según Comenta benigno
vecino del lugar por más de 50 años
el río estaba bonito todo el limpia agua
limpia agua que se podía bañar todo el
mundo ya digo que te apoyan hasta pescar
lo que quisiera por ahí camarones de
todo eso Pero qué va a medir el tiempo
fue avanzando
añadiéndose tantas
Barriada tanta más gente y más gente
creciendo la comunidad el pueblo la
población Así mismo Claro que todo eso
va llegando a donde al solamente al río
es el único que hay son miles de litros
de agua permanente que corren y terminan
afectando al ecosistema Marino
principalmente los corales Carolina que
forma parte de un equipo científico del
smithsonian Investiga el impacto de las
aguas servidas
no todas las zonas tienen corrientes que
puedan que hacer que estas aguas se
mezclen y se combinen con agua fresca
que no que te que tengan una baja
descarga de O sea que tenga pocos
nutrientes Entonces
si no es una zona que hay un gran
movimiento de agua ya sea por viento o
por corrientes o si es una Bahía
semicerrada estos estanca la
contaminación de las aguas son parte de
los 19 problemas ambientales directos
que ha identificado el Ministerio de
ambiente de Panamá en la actualidad se
ejecuta un proyecto de saneamiento de la
Bahía de Panamá que garantizaría su
limpieza total en 2050 para evitar que
la contaminación urbana llegue a los
océanos
mientras otras regiones del país
experimentaban horas de calor y
temperaturas inusualmente altas para
esta época del año el estado de
California en Estados Unidos resultó
impactado por intensas Nevadas que
dejaron a miles de personas atrapadas en
sus hogares Y llevaron incluso al cierre
indefinido del parque nacional y
eusemirí muchos expertos señalan que
podrían tratarse de nuevas
manifestaciones de la crisis climática
el siguiente informe es de nuestra
cadena aliada
este hombre llevaba 48 horas encerrado
en su casa
su Vivienda Está rodeada de increíbles
muros de nieve con equilibrio inestable
si bien se trata de una región montañosa
estos pueblos californianos no habían
visto un fenómeno semejante desde hace
40 años no tenemos a dónde ir la nieve
me llega por encima de los hombros están
alrededor de toda la casa empezó hace ya
siete días ahora se está poniendo muy
difícil
ayúdenos han escrito los habitantes de
chrisline en la nieve mientras llega la
ayuda lo urgente es limpiar los tejados
si Calcula que en promedio hay de 500 a
600 kilogramos de nieve por metro
cuadrado esto es demasiado para los
marcos de algunas casas ni siquiera el
supermercado resistió se organizan
distribuciones de alimentos en la calle
y hay muchas personas familias aisladas
que ya no tenían nada de comer en sus
casas el sol vuelve la ayuda se organiza
poco a poco algunas familias atrapadas
por fin son rescatadas
no sé cómo agradecerles estamos tan
aliviados tan felices de volver a la
vida normal me siento tan abrumada a
veces hay nevadas en el Sur de
California pero nunca tan fuertes ni
durante tanto tiempo
Es difícil entender la magnitud de este
fenómeno para nosotros que estamos en el
Sur de California
muchos científicos atribuían estas
Nevadas sin precedente a la crisis
climática en Estados Unidos estos
fenómenos extremos son noticia todos los
días nieve en California huracán en
Texas este Tornado filmado ayer es el
número 180 en tres meses los daños son
diarios todas las regiones del país
están ahora en alerta
queremos agradecer a la verbena
literaria por prestarnos sus
instalaciones para la realización de
este programa y a ustedes también Muchas
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información
[Música]